okay do you have any plans for
Valentine's Day are you one of those
oh well that goes all out you we
definitely eat a lot together always
that's like an estate engine why this is
my house yeah we'll just binge and drink
we're drinking wine okay yeah we read
girl white girl just curious read nice
g2r yeah
I heard something about you know that
you've always wanted to be a mom right
yes and we are doing IVF right now
actually it sounds like just a process
that so many people go through it now
since I process but it's kind of
hardcore I've had friends go do that
yeah yeah so this Valentine's Day I'll
be getting shots in my butt
that my husband hormones very romantic
yes yeah but the hormones are very
intense and you know so many people they
go through this I mean and you know we
don't talk about it enough I think as
women and you know just we need to raise
more understanding and awareness and I'm
glad that's why I was so happy you
wanted to talk about this day because I
have friends I went through and I mean I
went through some serious depression
felt shame like was like what was wrong
with me like tried everything under the
Sun and sometimes it just doesn't happen
and you just need science to kind of
help move it along
yes and it's actually it's such a
miracle what they can do like that's a
miracle and of itself you know um
did you always picture selfie a mom yeah
definitely you're the baby of the family
and you always wanted kids
we're like opposite you know I'm not I'm
okay older sis oh you're getting that me
go but I had like a little baby carriage
though you know and a baby doll that was
my sister and then she'd curl my hair
and excellent burned me it was fine but
yeah you're my sister's bangs your yeah
that's what my sister could do I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this